it's great to welcome to the program
today bill von hippel who's a professor
of psychology at the university of
queensland in australia and also author
of the book the social leap the new
evolutionary science of who we are where
we came from and what makes us happy uh
so great to have you on today i really
appreciate it
oh thanks for having me david so i mean
i guess to pick somewhere to start
there's often conversations about
when when were humans modern and when
would we look at past
humans and say yeah at least physically
and generally speaking
that's the same sort of species that
that is us
um but there's maybe a little bit less
time paid in popular culture to what was
humanity like at sort of some of those
earlier stages so maybe we go to the
kind of rainforest to savannah phase
talk to us a little bit about what would
be the big differences we'd notice i
guess
sure so if you go back to when we were
still the same species as our cousins
the chimpanzees so we're talking six or
seven million years ago living in the
rainforest all the data that we have
suggests that we would look a lot like
modern chimps not exactly but awfully
close and then when we left the
rainforest and moved to the savannah and
actually it was the rainforest that left
us it dried out in the region that we
were on but when we left it moved to the
savannah
we were still probably very chimp-like
for a long time and in fact if you
fast-forward the clock about three
million years to australopithecines
you could see them standing next to a
chimp and the primary difference between
them would be that the
australopithecines can stand straight up
that they're completely bipedal but they
they look awfully a lot like a chimp
they
um in their structure and almost
everything else about them
it doesn't look like we're moving
anything toward humanity it's not really
until about 1.7 million years ago maybe
two million years ago when we get to
homo erectus that we start to see an
ancestor who you would expect to be on
your side of the glass at the zoo rather
than on the other side
when we talk about modern humans it is
the best science we have still that that
phase goes back about 250 000 years
yeah that's a that's a great number the
downside of course is that there wasn't
one day where we were or weren't humans
and then were right and so it's very
slow spread when you look at fossils
that are a little older than that you
start to see features that don't look a
lot like modern humans but just a few
and when you look at fossils that are
younger than that you even occasionally
see things that look a little archaic as
well
there are many efforts made by sometimes
i don't want to say modern psychology
like pejoratively but but by some modern
psychologists sometimes to explain
certain
uh responses that we humans have today
to certain stimuli by telling stories
about what things would have been like
when humans were on the savannah you
know the idea of the the fight-or-flight
response which we might have now in
public speaking you often hear analogies
too well
it's better to err on the side of if
there might be a lion coming to have
sort of that reaction another example is
i recently spoke to an expert on uh
sleep paralysis and other conditions and
we talked about the very common dream of
falling and his idea was that may go
back to when we were in the trees and
there would be an evolutionary advantage
to
having that kind of startle response
even when it's only a dream that you
were falling because it might you might
really be sort of falling out of a tree
those stories how useful do you think
they really are in kind of thinking
about our past
i think they're useful sometimes but
they're really primarily useful in
developing hypotheses and so if you
think well public speaking maybe that's
some sort of ancient response to to
lions or saber-tooths on savannah
something like that well you need to
explore that hypothesis and say what
does that tell us now personally i
wouldn't think that would get you
anywhere because what was a bigger deal
to our ancestors was no longer
saber-toothed on the savannah but the
possibility that our group might reject
us and if ever there's a chance to my
group reject me all at once is when i'm
publicly speaking and i'm saying
something to everybody if i say
something wrong that's a great chance
for them all to agree all right time to
give bill the hepo which for our
ancestors was a death sentence that's
interesting that's interesting so and i
think and you've written quite a bit
about
how social behavior
may be heavily dictated today by our
ancient ancestors and the evolutionary
pressures so that would be taking a it's
the same story that's often told but
it's really applying more of a social
interpretation to it than a bio
biological one i guess
absolutely and then the key is you need
to find a way to try to test it and most
of the research that we've done for
example on rejection shows that our
responses are way stronger than they are
to the fear of um
predators and other physical stimuli a
cliff you might fall off something like
that
the social rejection thing jonathan
height has written about this a little
bit and and also including in terms of
uh religiosity where in the past
if you didn't go with the predominant
beliefs of the clan it might increase
the odds that you get rejected and at
the time it was much more
it was less trivial to be socially
rejected maybe than it is now in terms
of our survival where now one could
argue i don't really have to be part of
a church or i can even be a loner and at
least
stay alive to a greater degree
um can you talk a little bit about how
that that rejection risk has really
changed over time
well the funny thing about that
rejection risk is as you say it hardly
matters anymore not only would you and i
be just fine if all of our friends
decided they didn't like us because we
could still survive but even more
importantly we could move to a new
neighborhood and get a new set of
friends but our ancestors didn't live
like that they lived in groups that were
relatively closed so to speak they broke
up and and regathered but in only within
a relatively small clan and so they
couldn't afford to risk their reputation
in the same way that you and i can today
and this is the exact kind of
evolutionary disconnect that you were
talking about earlier in our past it
mattered a great deal now it probably
doesn't matter as much but there's
nothing more painful to people than
rejection and there's nothing that
drives us more than people make in front
of us people doing the kinds of things
that we see our hunter-gatherer
ancestors do before they reject a member
of the group they ostracize them they
tease them ostracizing and teasing make
us feel terrible because those ancestors
who wouldn't respond to that are the
ones who then they took the next step
and they gave them the hepo
thinking still along these lines i've
heard folks like for example jordan
peterson
make the argument that
the
possibility of a physical confrontation
between men
that's kind of he he would say
always there in in the kind of
background and socially important
is a driving factor in many ways for the
advancement of society in some way and i
say this both as someone who i hope i'm
representing accurately what he said and
i'm also not a peterson fanboy i've been
very critical of many things he said i'm
just interested in the idea that there's
this when men interact in society in
western society at least
there's the possibility that if things
don't go well it may devolve into a
physical confrontation can you talk a
little bit about whether that's a
conflict with what others say is the
human kind of proclivity for peaceful
relations rather than than
violent relations and see if we can make
a little bit of sense out of that
yeah that's a great question so if you
look at our chimpanzee cousins they're
about 500 times as likely to come into
physical conflict with other members of
their group than humans are and so when
we look at human hunter-gatherers so
there's no police to stop you no
government we see a ratio of 500 to one
for every one conflict we have where we
fight with each other over something
they have 500 but if you look at our
chimpanzee cousins when they interact
with members of other groups now you see
a one-to-one ratio they're exactly as
conflicted with members of other groups
as we are or we are exactly as much as
they
and so basically we've we've evolved to
be hyper cooperative we work together
incredibly well but that's primarily
within our groups
when we're looking at between group
relationships they look a lot like
chimpanzees did and so human males in
particular are the ones who when the
conflict comes they tend to get into it
but if you look at us within our groups
although we form shallower relationships
than human females do on average those
shallow relationships allow us to kind
of form coalitions that dissipate and
then that reform later without any hard
feelings but those coalitions almost
never get foreign when we cross group
boundaries and that's where we see the
real violence that's part of our nature
is the explanation for this simply that
if you work together rather than fight
with each other everybody's more likely
to survive both as a species and as a
community and as an individual
well yes and and the reason that the
chimpanzees never crossed that
particular rubicon is they never got to
the point that we got to on the savannah
where there was enormous benefit to be
gained if everybody would cooperate and
so when you look at chimpanzee
psychology they're very clever they do
lots of things very well but they're
fundamentally competitive with one
another as a consequence the individual
goals and the group goals never aligned
whereas once we moved to the savannah
once we became bipedal and now we could
protect ourselves from predators now our
individual goals came into alignment
with our group goals and as a
consequence it benefited us individually
to cooperate and it made us incredibly
successful as an evolutionary story
that's very interesting in thinking back
i mean there's some characteristics that
now seem sort of trivial like for
example eyesight you know you're wearing
glasses i wear contact lenses it's not a
big deal you know we adjust the
prescription as needed and we can
imagine a time in the past where that
might have conferred a much more
significant
disadvantage to us sort of as as
individuals if we think about
the humans that have been leaders
in
early clans and humans that are leaders
now
have the characteristics changed
significantly or have they sort of
remained the same from what we know
well it's um it's a bit of a
complicated story because if you look at
what we what our ancestors were almost
assuredly like for the longest time
which is immediate return
hunter-gatherers you eat today what you
killed today because you live pretty
much on the equator and meat rots pretty
quickly and so everybody shares it all
out in those societies there are no
paramount leaders there are leaders that
come and go as decisions are being made
and so maybe you're the best hunter and
when it's time to go on a hunt we all
turn to you and say okay david what do
you think where should we go now if you
come up with an idea we don't like we
still don't do it but you carry a little
more weight you have more prestige
because you're better at it but now it
comes time to look for water or
or find a new camp or try to decide how
to deal with those hostels around on the
other side of the ridge
somebody else might step forward with
the best plan and so
the
what makes leadership effective in
hunter-gatherer societies is that it's
very distributed and it's very
egalitarian
we shifted away from that when we moved
to um when we became agriculturalists
because now we can store food and create
stable coalitions etc but interestingly
the modern world is shifting back to
that and one way to look at this
disaster in ukraine is that you've got a
paramount leader who nobody's told no to
for a very long time and so it's harder
for him to create and assess whether an
idea is good than it would be for
somebody who's democratically elected
who who knows that they're at the will
the people they could come and go and
their ideas are more important and they
have to be more persuasive
so
does this uh i mean jared diamond has
written a little bit about you know when
the when the agricultural revolution
happened
you if you want to think about it very
mathematically all of a sudden there
were p people who started to be
responsible for producing way more
calories than they needed
and that caloric surplus sort of opened
the door to specialization which
includes
people who
raise kids and also people who think and
people who do politics and think about
law and that type of thing is that
caloric surplus the the beginning of
sort of the modern idea of leadership
and politicians
very much so and so once we became
sedentary and we could create a caloric
surplus that we could store you have to
be like i could create a caloric surplus
on the equator by killing a giraffe
right but it's going to be gone that's a
key point yeah right so being able to
store it is a major thing yeah exactly
so once we get to that point where we
can store it we see society shifts
dramatically now agriculture enabled
that for most humans but it wasn't
always agriculture there for example
hunter-gatherers in the pacific
northwest knew where these big salmon
runs were going to come through and so
they could create coalitions that could
defend them from other groups they could
catch all these salmon to enough to last
for a year almost dry them out and now
they've got food for a very long time so
whenever you can create or source
storable sources of energy you've got
the basis to build the kind of society
that we have whereby you can have
specialization everybody doesn't have to
be a hunter or a gatherer people can do
whatever they want because somebody else
can be responsible for generating that
caloric surplus
it's often very uh there's a lot of
black white writing about all of these
significant leaps forward like the
agricultural revolution the industrial
revolution and some some folks at least
seem driven to assign
good or bad to them overall which which
seems so fraught and difficult
i'm wondering if there's maybe a more
overarching theme that we could identify
about all of these leaps like for
example
a lot of these leaps bring the
opportunity for a lot of good but also
things that are not so good so for
example with agriculture we could say
well uh
all of the obvious good things and
specialization and potentially reducing
hunger at the same time you started
seeing you know animal-borne disease to
some degree you started seeing uh
inequality for the first time in terms
of hey a lot of people can actually
store the food for the future um is the
general thing that there's always going
to be some aspects that are problematic
with any advance
yeah i've never seen an advance that was
an unmitigated good there there's almost
always a cost now sometimes we don't
envision those costs until later and
sometimes we don't envision the benefits
till later the first agriculturalists
live shorter lives they have more
disease ridden and they were even they
were physically shorter than their
hunter-gatherer ancestors because their
diet wasn't as good so they actually
suffered a lot for us to benefit way
later you know weird deal would you take
a deal to say well in a thousand
generations things are going to be great
you'd say well no thanks i'll do
something else so that's one side of the
coin i think the internet is a good
example the other side of the coin it's
democratized knowledge it's made us more
we can connect with each other more
easily et cetera but it's also done
things like create an enormous amount of
work as everybody in the world sends me
an email with a request for something
it's created and used to be they'd have
to write me a letter and it was just too
much effort right it's created all sorts
of polarization as people can create
fake news sites and and literally your
job is to try to make it more persuasive
so
with all of these when we enhance our
abilities to communicate with each other
when we enhance our abilities to create
and store new things
we always there's almost always
something that's going to go wrong in
that context humans tend to be really
good at fixing those things and it's as
a rule we'd almost never want to go back
and say okay well let's get rid of the
internet let's start hunter gathering
again those things don't happen so we do
a great job of doing our best to fix
them but they're undeniably the problems
that accompany those changes yeah one of
the most interesting books
that addresses this specifically with
the internet
is that i've read is neil postman's book
technopoly uh where he talks about the
sort of i don't know if it's naivete but
the idea that
only sorting things out so that we only
get the good of any technology or
advancement
is such an impossibility that it's
almost not even worth trying it seems
better to just figure out how to deal
with and manage the bad
yeah i think that's a great point and
adam alter has a wonderful book called
irresistible where he also talks about
just social media and the technology
that goes with that and again all that
stuff is great but then it turns out
it's highly addictive and so it disrupts
people's lives because they start
replacing their in-person interactions
with interactions with screens and so
you've got
the the approach of technology you've
got the problems that come when you're
just psychologically too attached to
these things and you no longer live the
kind of life we actually evolved to live
etc every single time you've there's
pluses and minuses and you have to find
a way to navigate it one of the points
you make in your book
if i understand it correctly is that um
following or letting our evolutionary
needs lead us
leads to
more happiness all else being equal and
i think that that's super interesting
i'm also aware of ways in which it's
sometimes turned around and used in what
i would consider to be a negative way
like for example sometimes you will hear
that type of argument used by
those against gay marriage and gay
adoption etc to say that's not going in
the direction that evolution leads us
because two men by themselves can't
create
uh offspring and so it's a sign that we
should be anti-gay for example or
something like that which i know is not
your your point can you talk a little
bit about what you do mean by
happier by following evolutionary needs
sure so evolution
pushes us to do the things that help us
survive and reproduce and so to the
degree that we in the modern world
continue to do the things that helped
our ancestors survive and reproduce
they're going to make us happy and that
means forming good and long-lasting
relationships that means forming
romantic sexual relationships the um on
the gay point you raise an interesting
one there's actually good evidence from
my colleague brendan zeich that
homosexuality also evolved and that it
serves purposes as well and so the same
data applied whether you're gay or
straight that evolution wants you to do
the kinds of things that were in your
best interest now the disconnects the
problems emerge when you get to things
like
um
just when you get to evolutionary
mismatches between our ancestral
environment and today and so a good
example would be we evolved to be
interested in sexual variety because it
helps you sort of spread your genes into
more than one basket you're not taking
all putting all your bet on one person
but variety was so rare in our ancestral
environment that it wasn't that
disruptive to people's long-term
monogamous relationships whereas variety
exists every day outside my door i can
see a new person if i live in a city and
so it makes it really hard to stay in a
long-term relationship if you're a city
dweller in today's world because the
evolved psychology of our ancestors was
responding to the fact that they
probably were would know 100 people in
their entire lives there's no way
they're encountering a million and the
reason that this was less relevant you
say the variety was less present was it
just because we were in relatively small
groups that were homogeneous yeah yeah
we lived in groups between 20 and 60
people we only mixed with people who had
our same accent spoke our same language
if we ran into somebody who didn't do
that there was we were there was a risk
that they were an enemy we might be
friendly we might get into a conflict if
we were friendly we might even use that
as a chance for men or women to switch
groups to decrease in breeding etc but
we spend our whole lives in these small
nomadic groups that didn't run into that
many different people
one of the reactions uh that i often see
from 10 11 12 year olds when they you
know learn about evolution is
it seems as though we've stopped
evolving to some degree and and of
course you know when we think about
modern humans 250 000 years we sort of
seem to look the same and and so on and
so forth can we
think through a little bit more about
and this maybe this is more of a
futurism type question
what are the
evolutionary pressures
now exerting influence on humans again
now that we've solved a lot of the
things that used to kill us very early
yeah that's a great question so if we
look at our
at what are called evolutionary sweeps
which are genes that don't exist in the
past and then suddenly sweep through the
population we can see that in fact
they've been more frequent in the last
ten thousand years than they were in the
prior hundred thousand years so it kind
of it may look like we stopped evolving
our bodies haven't changed much but
there's been dramatic changes inside us
ways of uh learning to drink milk by
producing the lactase enzyme throughout
our whole lives lots of things like that
so evolution is still happening very
much at a rapid pace but the forces on
us are now different it used to be
survival and now survival is kind of
solved right for most of us we're very
fortunate that that modern medicine and
and
and agriculture have enabled us to to
not have to worry about our survival but
sexual reproduction is a big one our
ancestors could never disrupt the link
between sexual activity and reproduction
and so that guaranteed they'd have lots
of kids we can now disrupt that link
very easily and evolution made us want
to have sex because when we were back in
the day and and that desire was
important for our reproduction we didn't
understand how to create offspring so
we've not we don't have an evolved
desire to have kids we have an evolved
desire to have sex and an evolved
tendency to be nurturant to those
beings who come along because of our
sexual activity now that we can separate
out those two i could easily imagine a
world not so far from now
30 40 generations where there's just not
that many humans because most of us are
not interested in having children most
of us are interested in doing other
things
uh when we
uh i mean humans are
quite quite poor at making predictions
about what things are going to look like
in the future
given that um what types of changes
would you be thinking about when we
think about 500 years from now in terms
of homo sapiens
500 years from now i don't think you'll
see anything different physically
biologically that's too fast you'll see
a lot of cultural changes and i have no
idea what those might be you could
imagine a world with free energy and
then nobody works for a living you can
imagine lots of interesting
possibilities but as far as us our
bodies and stuff starting to look
different our evolution starting to
make us
different even psychologically
from an evolutionary basis you you'll
need at least a minimum of a few
thousand where you're going to start to
see things and there it's probably going
to have more to do with who desires to
reproduce and who doesn't and are there
differences in the traits between people
who desire to reproduce and who don't
right now those differences are
primarily a factor of how you live if
you're a city dweller you have fewer
kids and if you're a rural person if
you're well educated you're fewer kids
and if you're not but those are
lifestyle factors that push you down a
certain pathway what we don't know at
all is what's the psychology of somebody
who likes to have lots of kids and
what's the psychology of somebody who
doesn't and might those psychologies
then actually play an important role in
our evolution going forward right right
fascinating uh the book is the social
leap the new evolutionary science of who
we are where we came from and what makes
us happy where we come from now and what
makes us happy we've been speaking with
the book's author bill von hippel i
can't tell you how much i appreciate
your time today thank you
totally my pleasure great to chat with
you